this process in China are momentous
wherever they lead they are hugely
significant there haven't been protests
like this on the mainland since
Tiananmen Square in 1989 but why exactly
are people protesting
art was an apartment fire in the Far
Western city of arumchi that killed 10
people and rescue efforts were
reportedly hampered by locked down
restrictions but the fuse has been laid
over months of frustration at China's
zero covert policy it began burning at a
factory that makes iPhones in zhangjo
that saw Fierce anti-covered protests
last week instead of relying on vaccines
the Chinese have tried to eradicate the
virus with Draconian lockdowns some
people have been welded into their homes
reportedly others have starved because
they've been unable to get out
China has a formidable State security
apparatus it's already swung into action
sweeping up protesters as well as
detaining two foreign journalists
it'll be using facial recognition
cameras to track down others deploying
all the powers of a security
surveillance state
people are finding different ways of
protesting some carrying pieces of blank
white paper symbols of protest against
online censorship others have told
journalists they are protesting just by
watching others do so
China has seen big protests in Hong Kong
before and protests on Mainland China a
commonplace but they are small and
localized and easily contained we
haven't seen protests on this scale with
people out in their thousands and this
widespread happening in at least 10
cities since the pro-democracy process
of the 80s
those protests were crushed by tanks and
troops massacring hundreds of people
this is the first time since then we've
heard the Chinese openly calling for
their government to stand down foreign
leader Xi Jinping recently entrenched
for an unprecedented third term in power
has already launched a Crackdown on
these protests but he has a huge problem
with civil resistance against more
lockdowns and more protests covert is
likely to spike and his anti-covered
policies have failed China's synovac is
less effective than Western vaccines
which he could choose to use but with
that comes a loss of face the pandemic
could escalate leading to more unrest
and repression and the impact on the
country's economy could be enormous
which could bring even more people out
on the street this could all lead to a
spiraling crisis for the Chinese
government as it tries to bring things
under control